you have repeatedly criticized the
the vice president for not specifically
calling out antifa
and other left-wing extremist groups but
are you willing
tonight to condemn white supremacists
and militia groups
and to say that they need to stand down
and not
add to the violence in a number of these
cities as we saw in kenosha
and as we've seen in portland are you
prepared to do specifically
let's do it say i would say almost
everything i see
is from the left wing not from the right
what are you what are you
what are you saying i'm willing to do
anything i want to see people
do it sir say it do it say it do you
want to call him
what do you want to call him give me
your name give me a white surprise
and write presents stand back and stand
by
but i'll tell you what i'll tell you
what somebody's got to do something
about antifa and the left because this
is not a right-wing problem
this is a lefty director this is a
left-wing
white supremacist antifa is an idea not
an organization you've got it
not malicious that's what he is
your administration tells you the truth
is it has a bad idea did i tell you what
you have no idea
antifa is a danger gentlemen we're now
moving on to the trump records
what's up ladies and gentlemen my name
is wayne dupree and you are
looking live at tired individuals
we do this for you we love you we do
love you
right it's only for you we're served i
love
honestly to tell you truth i have not
slept since
i find that amazing wayne's been up for
24 hours i have been up
i've been up and i
have to say um i've been watching
many responses from my side the other
side
i looked at a lot of video i've tried to
go to sleep
and i i i just can't remain sleep
last night well first off let me say
welcome to
all of our awesome awesome
followers awesome individuals that are
sharing the show thank you so much
for sharing the show we want to thank
all of
everybody that was watching last night
uh people giving comments
uh let me introduce leah blue eyes bella
um that's right thank you so much for
watching last night it was a long night
to say the least
yeah make sure today you're clicking
that share button and shout out to all
the watch parties that are going on
thank you for watching but make sure you
are sharing the show that's the most
important thing because we are being
suppressed uh we have proof of it so
just keep sharing
and then we have the bishop mr brian
smith what's up me
hey guys what's going on um yeah
cnn got it right this time what an
absolute chill last stock yeah
and and what and what brian is talking
about is this i
um i will talk about who won the debate
who lost the debate but i can tell you
one thing for sure the american people
lost
tonight because that was horrific
you just took the words out of my mouth
um you use some high-minded language i'm
just gonna
say it like it is that was a [ __ ] show
and
you know we're on cable we can say that
apologies for being
um maybe a little bit crude but that is
really the
the phrase that i'm getting more you
know from people on both sides of the
aisle on
texts and
it was and and
um the reason why i'm not calling out
cnn
for this and uh if there's one thing
that i know
is both sides y'all i know both sides
because
i was a former democrat and
i am i'm an independent conservative and
after watching a whole lot of responses
last night
i'm almost jumping into the libertarian
party
but i was talking with my daughter my
daughter is 17
17. i didn't watch the debate with her
this morning as a matter of fact did you
say she watched it with her friends
she was talking about the debate with
her friends okay they were 17
18 years old girls that are going to
vote
or uh girls that are one year away from
voting
okay and let me tell you something they
were confused
frustrated angry turned off
welcome to the last four years girls and
that
and that was for people that had not
participated in voting
that were trying to make up their mind
about what they were going to do
and they saw two like they saw
grown men up there going back and forth
yeah my 12 year old and 11 year old
daughter both of them
watched the whole show with my wife
they actually watched our show they said
we did an awesome job they loved it
and the first words out of my mouth the
first question i asked all three of them
i said who won tonight all three of them
said chris wallace right
he he accomplished what he set out to do
i asked my husband the same thing who do
you think won and he said
well you can't have a referee
siding for one team right right
and he said he thought it was a shame
that trump had to go two against one
and he thinks that
there has to be some type of fair
moderation
and we can't get it anymore from someone
who's in the media no longer can our
moderators be someone from the media
we can't trust it we we should have
known this from the beginning
shame on everybody for allowing it to
happen i don't know how you stop it
but the next moderator needs to be
someone bipartisan someone who's not in
the media
who can speak well who can just read a
question and then say president you have
two minutes
you mute joe biden's speaker i mean uh
microphone
you let him talk and then when it's joe
biden's turn you mute trump for two
minutes and then when it's open session
you open both mics
until it gets out of control then you
mute both that's how you do it and the
moderator
doesn't say a word the mute button can
do exactly what a moderator can do
we don't need moderators and chris
wallace proved that last night
yeah right yeah i don't know how you
undo this yeah i don't know how you undo
it
yeah and and and and i'm watching and
i'm watching some
people in the chat room talk about a
wire
and stuff like that you know what i was
awake when y'all
when that start when that started to go
online and i
and i couldn't believe that
conservatives were doing it
y'all need to stop i really couldn't i
couldn't believe that they were doing
that
even if he was it doesn't matter
let me um let me do something for a
second
you see this right here
you see that line right there crease
yeah he had he had a crease in his shirt
and then and then when he moved
it went just like that on the right side
wayne why are you wearing a wire
but they but but watching people
they thought it was a wire they really
thought it was a wire
and then if you look at the video
another 10-15 minutes
let me uh it was on this
it was on this side it was on this side
outside of his um his his thing i'm like
i cannot believe that they're trying to
blame us on a wire oh okay i tell you
what
i tell you what could it have been
and i know we were making a joke about
it yesterday could it have been
uh the pampered depends type of thing
cather uh could it have been something
um because he couldn't go to the
bathroom well that's just it and that's
why i'm actually silent on this because
when i first saw the police shooting
that happened where the two police
officers were shot the video camera
to me it looked like a [ __ ] to me it
looked like an actual [ __ ] was
shooting the police
it did or a child and then they i found
out that the camera angle
actually skewed our vision of how tall
that person was that person was actually
six foot something but it looked like he
was so tiny because of the camera angle
therefore i can't comment on it because
i don't know if it was or wasn't a wire
i don't know if it was a crease or
wasn't a crease
i can't tell right now right and
here's the thing so many people are so
okay
let's say let's say it was a wire how
how is he getting the information
and if it wouldn't have anything in his
ear right if it was a wire
same thing with wire say it was a wire
say
he was getting information in his ear do
you think that
actually helped him last night no it
didn't
it didn't help not even close no it
didn't so don't go down that road
that's a road you shouldn't travel
because it just it didn't help them it
didn't
get the end going down that rabbit hole
the end of that road
leads to nothing no good right i mean
you guys are sending me links you're
sending me pictures
i know stop it with the links
to me to me it just makes us look
it makes us look crazy it does it it
makes it look crazy trump
look trump already was um it was two
against one
everybody it was two against one um
chris wallace made it seem like it was
um uh on the chris wallace show or um
the sunday it looks just like a white
house press event against trump
and and and we all knew that
we all knew that when trump asked biden
questions
biden couldn't answer it and he was
trying to defer
every time if he was listening to
somebody with a wire
with somebody with some information he
would have came back and
would be able to respond to president
trump
with everything that president trump was
throwing at him and he couldn't every
every time trump got him he
he would go like this that's not true
that's not true
if you're not going to engage it doesn't
make sense there's a guy that calls
himself an investigative
journalist and podcaster on the youtubes
or on the twitters
and he sent me pictures of what might
be in the sleeve i'm like the thing is
you're an investigative journalist but
it doesn't help either
whether he had a wire or not like wayne
said and you brian it really didn't
matter
because it was a terrible debate you
cannot have a good debate with a bad
moderator
you can and that's exactly what happened
last night
and so neither side won in my opinion
nobody won that
no the only thing i can pray for that
happens out of this is we
learn our lesson with moderators they
cannot be in the media
and we need to be able to mute out joe
biden when trump is talking and mute
trump when joe is talking
and that is the end of it the next one
is c-span the guy
from c-span uh sully he's a
correspondent
for c-span and washington journal
and he does a tv show in the morning
uh another media i'm sick of it
it's uh he looks kind of soy boyish so i
don't know how that's gonna work
out but um chris wallace came
with an agenda uh he threw both fists
and trump even early on said what what
what are you going to do
is debate with you and me that's fine
okay let's roll yeah and and that's what
that's that's the main thing that i took
that's the main thing that i took
from from president trump last night is
that
it was it was a huge two-on-one i mean
if
yeah it was a huge two-on-one uh
wallace threw those early questions out
there a couple days ago
as as like uh
uh i don't know some type of
some type of uh suppression fire but
then
when he got in he had his own agenda and
their own agenda
was to call out president trump that's
why when you saw the white supremacy
thing i was like
but wait a minute i i know president
trump has um
uh called out white supremacy before
so why in the world would you do it now
i mean
that's what the media has been doing to
president trump uh
for the last three years even though
he's like
when uh it was a david duke thing
trump has called our david duke a couple
of times but they kept on going after
him they kept
well you need to but i've already done
it how many times
else do you want me to do it you know
but um
again while it's supposed to be a bash
on trump like his question with the
you paid 750 in income tax well if
you're going to do that then you need to
call joe biden for his you ain't black
or you know that's not going to gap yeah
or why don't you bring up hunter biden's
uh
millions of dollars and did you know
about that he didn't call out joe
one time he was also trump planted
questions
well he cut trouble a lot of times when
trump brought up no trump was going to
bring up uh the
hunter biden's in the money and the
breezman
we're done talking here we're done
that's
exactly what they said did what i just
said to you is what chris did to drunk
we're not we're not we're done go ahead
yo go ahead joe talk
it's true you're done i can't believe it
i can't believe it
chris wallace interrupted joe biden 15
times and president trump
76. yeah right gentlemen
which was the president you would have
been much later
mr president you're talking about two
million people you're not president as a
moderator
we are going to talk about covet in the
next segment but go ahead
i don't know well all right let's all
right let's talk
we've got a lot to unpack here gentlemen
we've got a lot of time so
joe individual mandate was the most
unpopular aspect of obamacare i got rid
of it i'd like to
we will protect president i'm the
moderator of this debate
and i would like you to let me ask my
question and then you can answer it go
ahead
first of all i guess i'm debating you
not him but that's okay i'm not
surprised
open discussions
sir you'll be happy i'm about to pick up
on one of your points
to ask the vice president that is going
to end private
if i start insurance you the question uh
it will that's what your party says by
the way
radical left what are you sure listen
who is on your list joe
this is who's on your own right
gentlemen i think this is
unbelievable we're not going to give a
we have ended this segment that's the
end of the segment we're moving we're
moving on
it didn't take them vice president can i
be honest it's a very important try to
be honest
no the answer to the question is no
ukraine no i
sir with a billion dollars that is
absolutely you know what you're waiting
for you're doing it you're going to have
that true gentleman
is i hate to raise my voice
why shouldn't i be different than the
two of you we i think that
the country would be better served if we
allowed
both people to speak with fewer
interruptions i'm appealing to you sir
to do that
well and him too well frankly you've
been doing more interruptions that's all
right but he does plenty
well less than sir
mr president your campaign agreed to
both sides would get two minute answers
uninterrupted well
your side agreed to it and why don't you
observe what your campaign agreed to as
a ground rule okay sir he never keeps
his words no
no no i'm not actually that was a
rhetorical question
saying to a crowd not a hot mic
if you don't fire the guy investigating
my
son you don't get the money i'll be
damned he was fired
you can't bring that up i just
i just wish me myself i just wish
that president trump would have allowed
joe to hang himself a little bit more
i'm with you and maybe he'll get that
advice i mean the people around him are
good people
connie trump had a lot of
great questions for biden and when and
and and
and for those purists out for those
individuals that know politics and i'm
talking about the emotional
um warriors on social media i'm talking
for those that really know politics
right
you all saw that joe biden couldn't
answer a lot of stuff
that president trump was throwing out
there yeah y'all saw that
right and every time when joe got to a
place
where he couldn't answer and he was
looking for answer
and you'd be like okay well yeah trump
got him here
trump would just step right on his foot
and say go ahead and answer answer what
what you're waiting for because i'm
right you're right
you know what else i noticed in those
clips i think that if trump would have
just let him keep going
that chris would have saved his butt
though too because chris was throwing
him out
life support so i'm not sure if we would
have heard
a joe gaff because every time joe would
forget a question
right well he would remind him what the
question was now joe the question is
is it a v-shape or a k-shape you said
k-shape
right right as soon as joe would say
something he'd throw him a life jacket
again
but america would have saw that a whole
lot
more yeah than the crap show that would
that happened last night where i mean
honestly
that reminded me of me and my ex-wife
man i
that mean terrible i'm serious i'm
i mean it got to a point that i was
looking at both of y'all
and y'all and i mean and all of us are
going oh
man it was terrible that it's a direct
reflection of a bad moderator
too it really is it's like a husband and
wife and
the lord another family member trying to
stop the husband and wife from fussing
you know you know what i'm saying it's
like
okay wait a minute okay but hold on
whatever and like
nobody learned anything from it but i
still think
that if president trump would have given
a little bit more time because joe was
searching for the answers
and that's why i don't believe that's
why i don't believe in this wire [ __ ]
okay i don't believe in the wire because
if he had had the wire somebody would
have been feeding them to questions and
he would have been back on it
so guess what the wire so if there was a
wire
it didn't work right now for anybody
who's saying trump didn't denounce white
supremacy
okay fine but chris also said will you
denounce blm to joe biden and joe biden
ignore the question went on to something
else and chris didn't call him out on it
he would not denounce that either you
know what
did he say will you deny i yeah yeah and
i'm that's what i'm actually trying to
find now the training
i got it i got it bernie sanders
task force you talked about quote
reimagining policing first of all what
does
reimagining policing mean and do you
support
it means let me if i might finish the
question what does reimagining
policing mean and do you support the
black lives matter
uh call for uh
for community control of policing look
what i support is the police having the
opportunity to deal with the problems
they face
and i'm not totally opposed to defunding
the police officers
as a matter of fact police local police
the only one defunding in his budget
calls for a 400 million dollar cut in
local law enforcement assistance
they need more assistance they need when
they show up for a 9 11 call to have
someone with them as a psychologist or
psychiatrist
to keep them from having to use force
and be able to talk people down
we have to have community policing like
we had before where the officers get to
know the people
in the communities that's when crime
went down
it didn't go up it went down and so we
have to be
that's not what they're talking about
chris that's not where that
the police that is not true he doesn't
have any law
with your support he has no law
enforcement that's not true
who do you have name one group that
supports you name one group that came
out and supported you
go ahead i think we have time we don't
have time to do anything
all right one law enforcement group
that came back gentlemen i think i'm
going to i'm going to take back the
moderators
and i want to get to another subject
which is the issue of protests
in many cities that have turned violent
in portland oregon especially we had a
more than a hundred straight days of
protests
which i think you would agree where you
talk about peaceful protests many of
those turned into riots
mr vice president you say that
people who commit crimes should be held
accountable
the question i have though is as the
democratic nominee and earlier tonight
you said that you are the democratic
party right now
have you ever called the democratic
mayor of portland or the democratic
governor of oregon and said
hey you've got to stop this bring in the
national guard
do whatever it takes but you'd stop the
days and months of violence
in portland i don't hold public office
now
i am a former vice president i've made
it clear
i've made it clear in my public
statements that the violence should be
prosecuted
it should be prosecuted and anyone who
commits it but you've never called for
the people
the leader excuse me sir you had never
called for the leaders
in portland and in oregon to
call us bring in the national guard and
knock off a hundred days of riots
they can in fact take care of it if he
just stay out of the way
look here oh really here oh really
nobody get the killer of the young man
in the middle of the street and they
shot him for three days president trump
didn't do anything
go ahead sir and by the way you know his
own former spokesperson said
you know riots and chaos and violence
help us cause
that's what this is all about i don't
know who said that i do
i think kellyanne conway i don't think
she said she said that
and so here's all right
okay going back to the blm
thing that you were talking about he
didn't specifically ask him to denounce
no and he didn't specifically answer the
question either well
he totally dodged it right right but it
didn't happen
but it didn't have anything to do with
denouncing blm
right isn't that a shame it was right
and he
should have isn't that a shame and
chris asked donald trump to denounce all
the white people
right you can't announce a terrorist
group that doesn't even want the nuclear
family to be
there but then okay well i mean okay
well then he should have did it on his
own but then chris wallace should have
asked him the question too
if chris wallace is going to ask trump
that question then he should
then he should ask biden and he did not
but
whoa well now go out and say
that um he did that um that he was asked
the question
and he punted on the announcement blm
because he wasn't asked about it he was
asked about the defend
the funding of the situation of that was
happening
and then as soon as trump said you don't
have one police department backing you
up what does chris do
okay we're done with this conversation
but but then but then we'll go back to
what we were talking before
biden was biden was in flames he was
clueless he was looking right
looking again and then and then trump
just jumped right in there
and what that that made that made um
wallace
said but wait a minute hold on i mean
i'm trying to get through i agree with
that i agree leo
that chris would have uh walked in and
saved joe from having to answer that
question there's no question about that
but if you see that exchange that was a
long experience it was a wrong one
and flames right between uh
biden two questions and chris wallace
and completely cut trump out trump
comments because he's got to get in
yeah and then chris shuts it down right
there there was one particular time last
night
where wallace was going back and forth
with trump
and it seemed like it was for 10 minutes
and
and and if you had the split screen you
look
at biden was catching almost a second
win
it looked like biden was was was uh um
was
catching his breath trying to uh get
himself back together again
because he didn't jump in he didn't jump
in when both of them were talking
he was quiet well and as a moderator
you're not supposed to laugh
whenever trump says nobody's going to
show up your rallies joe
a moderator should not have laughed at
that he should not have left
i'm just going to be fair here just like
he should not have jumped
on trump when trump was trying to finish
a sentence and he said
trump you've been interrupting us more
than joe has that's
not something you say that was immature
and that was not
needed and then when joe said i can't
remember what you were going to ask me
chris wallace comes to his savior so
that way no one can say it was dementia
yeah me too me too joe i can't remember
either because trump's being so
confusing
chris should have never did that shame
on chris he i i really think he's gone
he was rare
yeah yeah he was bad he was bad he was
bad horrible
his bad the whole time i i just i just
um
and and i'm not saying that uh president
trump shouldn't be able
to get his point across because
president trump got his point across
many times last night is
it's just that i just think many many
times he snatched
um defeat
the victory victory out of the jungle
by jumping into the conversation when
when joe was falling out okay we got a
great patreon that's following us for a
long long long time he's a real good guy
his name's bill
and he texts me and he said um actually
i think
trump won he separated joe from his base
he went against antifa saying law and
order
he dumped the green new deal for some
imaginary biden plan
he tacked to the middle among
other areas bernie bros not going to be
happy
the rest was noise yeah i mean joe did
say antifa was just an idea
joe did did tell trump to shut up
which is completely disrespectful he
also called him a clown
and this is after his after joe and
obama's administration spied on the poor
man
and now we know that that's the truth
then you call the clown you call him the
worst president ever you tell him to
shut up
and you say antifa is just an idea
man we see your agenda aot
has responded about joe's claim about
not backing
back in the new because joe biden did
say the green deal was not my plan
yep that's that's what he said uh
and she has she responds with um
this isn't news oh um
kellyanne conway actually called called
out yeah
don't sniff me that particular situation
and so did i
uh but alc says our differences are
exactly why i joined biden's climate
unity task force so we could set aside
our differences and figure out an
aggressive climate
plan to address the planetary crisis at
our feet
trump doesn't even believe climate
change is real um
so for her i mean it's not the first
time that he
is uh thrown her green deal out but
if you listen to how how he was
describing it last night he said she
you remember that okay he said she i was
like
okay well biden said she yeah
biden was basically talking about aoc's
plan
that he sounded like he was on board but
even though he said that he wasn't on
board
he said well it's her um
she something something i was like well
damn you just you
man you you're just confused but yeah um
uh biden uh decided that he was going to
go
low uh with um how he treated president
trump
and um honestly i was shocked i was
shocked that he told president trump
that i am i'm
i'm i was shocked that he said it uh
and but watching other people
other people online last night uh
president trump has did a whole lot of
stuff in the last three years
in saying a whole lot of stuff to a
whole lot of people so
um with biden doing that
on the on the national you could tell
that he was frustrated
and if he was frustrated
i mean why would a man who was wearing a
wire be frustrated if he was getting all
the information that he was supposed to
be getting
yeah he wouldn't be and trump did get in
his good licks
i've done more than 14 months 47 months
than you've done in 47 years that was a
great one
telemundo who we know a little biased
they came out with a poll and they
pulled viewers
i'm assuming the poll was spanish
viewers are hispanic viewers
they said it was a 60 30 win for trump
in their poll i saw that and um then uh
what's your name from the white house uh
mcinnini macanandi um tweeted out that
cnn did a real live poll
say we're like two to one trump a live
vote
the problem is when i watched it there
was like
15 to 20 people there and only three
people voted
only three people voted because
everybody else kept kept their hands
down
it was two people that voted for trump
one person voted for biden and everybody
else
put their hand down on on who won so it
was a two to one
yeah literally and everybody else put
their hands down
and then and then cnn did another vote
uh later on and it was 60 to 30.
yeah biden oh 60 34 biden
60 to 30 something but 60 to 28 or 60 to
30 something biden yeah
wow yeah but you know i find that
shocking because i don't think biden put
on
uh he didn't answer questions he didn't
put out policy that was not he was
stagnant yeah i wasn't impressed there
was no wow factor for me with
with joe last night it was singing in it
was cnn
yeah i don't think that the suede voters
right or left i don't i think that if
you were
undecided you're still undecided and
maybe you're even a little bit more
confused now
and uh honestly i know that everybody
wants to say that this was a terrible
debate and it was the worst debate
they've ever seen
but i think you always have to try the
silver lining in the goodness
and honestly if there's any good that
comes out of this
it's that the left finally sees how
mistreated
trump has been because they were
complaining that joe didn't get to talk
at all
well now you know how trump feels yeah
now you know how trump feels
and what was that interruption again for
uh chris wallace interrupted joe
and trump 76 times
that's beyond unbelievable not only that
but in the middle of trump's
answering to wallace yes he's got the
right to talk
he's like a two-minute right to talk
wallace interrupted him
three times in a minute and a half
yeah yeah bro yeah i mean
look president trump had again i mean
this
honestly and leah i i
understand you about looking for the
silver line this is worse than 2006
it is it's the worst debate ever it's
the worst debate ever
i mean ever in the history of debates
yeah i i mean
that wasn't even the that was a what
[ __ ] show
the powers that be the powers that be
last night
all had champagne popped the corks and
said yes
you got through this you were like two
more
times i've seen three-year-olds work out
their differences better
than what i saw last night i really have
and so and
um so many people are saying that joke
that um joe biden
um probably won't show up for the next
two let me go back
i told you he was gonna show up i told
you joe was going to be at the debate
and then right
see and that's what that's why i'm
getting mad at the conspiracy thing
about the wire because
many people oh he's going to show up
he's going to tap out at the last minute
he's not going to show up
camilo camilo's gonna i was like no i'm
telling y'all joe's gonna show up
because joe wants to be president
well let me defend myself because i was
one of them but what you don't
understand wayne is
i was watching joe on the campaign trail
coughing
in his hand and having shortness of
breath so i wasn't being conspiracy
theorists
by what i was seeing he looked ill and
then we have this huge
coven 19 supposedly out there killing
everybody you have a 78 year old man
coughing and hacking looking frail so
deductive reasoning tells me
that that there was a good chance that
he might not have shown up because he
was ill
right just like there could have been a
chance that maybe trump got coveted and
was sick and wasn't ill
that's why i was saying it because the
proof was in the pudding he was hacking
up
along for the last three weeks most of
you can't deny that
most of the things that i will and that
i saw online
was that he was on his deathbed that i
mean that
he uh he wasn't gonna survive and
he was gonna find a way out and uh
that's
that's what everybody has been saying
for the last four five six months
you know that he wasn't gonna be at the
debate the debate was gonna get called
off and i was like
no he's going to be there this is now
he did a bad show his time is to shine
and after the debate last night
the word and and the reason why i
thought that out for the last four or
five months
is because of the wire thing that
everybody's talking about i want you to
go i mean
there is a video there is a video that i
was watching this morning
that's why that's why i didn't get no
sleep there was a video that i was
watching this morning
that it was a close-up of
it's cuff right right here right right
investigative reporter said that at the
end of the video
it disappeared i mean it disappeared i
mean totally like
wait a minute but hit but the hand
didn't move
that just went blue and it didn't go
down it just disappeared
so i'm like okay okay but the reason why
i'm
merging that conspiracy with the wire
situation
is because now people are saying well uh
they probably won't do any more debates
after that joe biden's campaign is
coming out saying that
they don't think there should be any
debates
well that's not what was just said a few
minutes ago i'm not sure when this was
updated but now the campaign's saying
uh maybe it's better off if we don't
have debates i got that from the daily
wire this morning
um the deputy campaign manager squashes
skipping the beat says we are going to
do
the debates well that's great well i'll
be honest with you after last night
why would you skip them i know right
right right and
joe stood there for an hour and a half
right exactly
right right and that's and that's
another thing i want to yeah i'm
i'm glad you said that because that was
on my mind when i saw that i was like
why would you i mean everybody said
you're going to be falling out you can
be falling over
you're going to be going to sleep
waiting to wander around
yeah and i mean and he stood up there
now but i still believe
that the way that chris wallace ran that
stuff because actually the second debate
is sitting down
um but chris the way that chris wallace
did his thing and going back and forth
with trump
it gave biden time to collect the stuff
because he liked his thoughts
you know to to get stuff back because
there were a few times that joe was like
yeah and he was taking notes joe was
writing stuff down he was taking notes
and why in the heck would he be taking
notes
if he's not a wire
because you gotta jot down with her
whispering in your ear so you don't
forget it wayne come on now buddy
i mean that that had to be the most
invisible
earpiece i have ever seen if you on
the internets and the twitters and the
youtubes and the facebooks
if you want to be an investigative
journalist
and you're telling people that you are
and
you're going out there and you're saying
oh looky looky
what might this be that's not an
investigative journalist
it's dispiritorial you gotta let that go
you'll find out the facts
use some deductions some reasoning some
logic
yeah some common sense yeah um
leah he was talking about the shut up
thing that shocked everybody
it shocked everybody you don't do that
to a president then you just don't
that was what's the cuss word in our
house in our house
yeah shut up yeah yo no that it's you
might as well drop the f bomb in our
house
but but it was like
it was like he was so frustrated
that it was like a hot mic moment yeah
because
he really knew you shut up he was like
man
shut up you know okay kind of like that
you know if senate republicans
we were talking originally about the
supreme court here if senate republicans
go ahead
and confirm justice barrett uh there has
been talk
about ending the filibuster or even
packing the court adding
to the nine justices there you call this
a distraction by the president but in
fact it wasn't brought up by the
president
it was brought up by some of your
democratic colleagues in i'm saying the
congress
so my question to you is you have
refused in the past to talk about it
are you willing to tell the american
people tonight whether or not you will
support
either ending the filibuster or packing
the court whatever position i take and
that that'll become the issue the issue
is the american people should speak
you should go out and vote you're in
voting now
vote and let your senators know how
strong you feel
let vote now make sure you in fact
let people know we're senators i'm not
going to answer the question because you
can answer that because the question
is the question is justice radical left
would you listen who is on your list joe
this is on youtube right now
gentlemen i think this is unbelievable
we have ended this segment we're going
to move on to the second segment
he says this is so unpresidential you
just told the president to shut up
that's why it's so unpresidential
radical left and he got triggered
radical left judges got triggered
because he knows it they know it
they know they're going to pack the
court that they set it out of pure
frustration
uh nancy pelosi with quivers and her
arrows or
quill quivers yeah
flippers in her arrows right that was a
moment of frustration
from the left because they know they
can't
pack the court so it's a bully tactic
it's a threatening tactic
to just uh come out knee-jerk well we're
gonna pack the court you do
sobs yeah um
biden was uh frustrated many times last
night and
wallace came in for the save but
president trump trump
president trump is not stupid wow
because president trump saw what was
happening and he didn't say anything
early
he let it go he let it go and then
he made that uh that um
you know he said am i debating you you
know
that that um type of uh response but
the the fact that chris wallace
continued not only but if you even
listen to that clip you just played
chris wallace interrupted uh
biden too and he just like chris
get your damn question out your question
should not be this
this paragraph of of thoughts and ideas
and
and i'm really gonna wrap this up and
make this a little
no ask the damn question and then shut
the hell up
it reminds me it reminds me of a court
leading you know how
some attorneys are like he's leading the
witness
you know kind of like that or yeah he's
leading the witness so
yeah there were a couple of times where
he did uh
interrupt joe but those interruptions
were to clarify
right the interruption of trump was
too embarrassed right and stop trump
from asking
the real question need to be answered or
to stop trump from
closing joe or to stop trump from
exposing joe a few times there he wanted
to talk about ukraine and chris wallace
was like ah we're moving on we're moving
on but there's a video of him
he was on video in a crowd no
no this segment's over shut it down you
know his son what about his son
and and the mayor of russia giving him
3.5 oh you lied
and you in biden's face he was pregnant
no no
no then chris wallace was like change
the subject let's talk about coronavirus
instead
what concerns me the most is uh after
all this happened today i went
on to my liberal friends facebook
accounts and
you know i just wanted to see what they
were having to say because i like to get
both sides and
they were harping on trump's tax return
and trump's oh trump's a racist because
he wouldn't deny white supremacy
and let me just say this okay everybody
forgets
when we were worried every day and we
were in code red
for terrorist attacks does everybody
remember 9 11 because i sure do
okay under obama's watch you have you
had more than one terrorist attack over
here
okay isis was booming they created isis
and they were
booming founding fathers of isis
actually right yeah
so let's remind everybody of something
trump's 401k
trump's unpaid taxes are not going to
save you
from someone with a bomb on their chest
walking into disney world and blowing it
up
okay whether you're white or black a
terrorist doesn't care
your skin color they're going to blow
you up and you will
die but you know what we've been saved
because there's peace in the middle east
he totally annihilated isis we're safer
than what we've ever been
but you're going to worry about 750 and
trump so racist
you realize that money and racism
doesn't matter
when there's a terrorist attack and
they're just killing people everywhere
when you have aoc in there and omar in
there that is the kind of world that is
the kind of united states that you're
going to be living in
sharia law here you come and you won't
even be able to speak out about your
taxes
because you'll be getting your hand
chopped off so that's really worry about
what's deeper going on here
because joe biden and his cronies that's
what you'll get
you'll get obama administration on
steroids
coming at you more terrorist attacks
more shari law
and more riots right it'd be camilla
that'll be camella aoc ill-hand nancy
pelosi you'll have
all of them running this thing and what
are they all going to say brian
oh it's a tragedy that there was another
terrorist attack in new york city
it's a tragedy that there was a bombing
in disney world
that's what they're going to say that's
just how it goes sorry
that we're starting to become like
london and terrorists are just going
around stabbing people
sorry yeah that's the metallica sadiq
khan said that's what happens in big
cities just
just happens yeah the mayor of london
that's what you want i'll take trump
trump don't ever pay a tax return again
if you can keep on keeping us safe don't
ever pay tax return again
if you can make sure that isis isn't
killing us thank you
right uh you've got it all
in the world we can see it everywhere
see it down in venezuela
see it in cuba see it now in uh
sweden the uk europe london
they are so angry with the migrations
we are beyond lucky that we're separated
by the pond it's just too much water
but they're being totally and completely
invaded that's
what will happen to us when the left
gets back their control
because that's how they break down our
way of life
our society and erase our past
and usher in a new form of communism
called islam and you won't get rid of
islam because
islam is human beings
communism is an ideology in a government
form
now you've got human beings being
submitted
in in enslaved women enslaved
into this cult called islam
yeah i
and people don't think it can happen it
can happen very easily
i wish you would have said but i mean
it's selfish it's
it's a selfish thing to me but i i wish
you would have just said it
i wish you would have said right there
on the stage on the global stage that
he condoned white supremacy i don't care
i mean i know he said it before
i've and and we reported that he said it
before we've got video that he said
before
i'll say it again i mean it doesn't hurt
anything
um i just but for me
i just wish you would have said it you
know if you just said if he said it last
night
because then he wouldn't have given them
the left
more ammunition someone said he did go
read the text
they're gonna say they can't they're
gonna ask him again well actually no no
he did he said
sure sure but i'll condone him right and
and and but they went into antifa
and here's the thing though antifa is
real
white supremacy where are these kkk
people
where are they i live in ohio on the
west side of cincinnati
and there's all kinds of rumors that
just down the street from me in indiana
somewhere
there's all kinds of swaths of kkk
members and
organizations and i'm 47 years old
i never in my entire life seen or known
anybody that belongs to kkk where is
this white supremacy at
yeah well
if they are talking about they're
talking about richard spencer and his
group
which is on the left well
now they are they they tried to said it
was on the right
yeah on the left and i i know some older
folks
that say the extreme right is white
supremacy and you're completely wrong
because when you look at white supremacy
you look at the kkk and you break it
down
their ideologies and how they want the
government to be
they're on the left far left you know
you know it's funny
it's funny you say that because um i've
seen i've seen a couple of
i mean and this and this is immediate i
think
i think it's immediate trick but um you
remember ruby ridge
oh do i good god seared in my mind
they tried to label those people up
there
right ringers yep yeah
whites every report that you saw
they label them right wingers the same
thing
that they labeled the oklahoma bomber
yeah timothy mcveigh right wing
that he had been up there at ruby ridge
when that happened and no no
no actually mcveigh was in waco
and they also called david koresh a a
right winger too
right a christian right winger
but uh mcvay who they also called a
right-winger
so i don't know maybe it's a media
attempt to destroy uh
conservatism uh for the last
60 or 70 years like that but they have
consistently labeled
uh the right wing as a terrorist
organization because now organization
um uh the
the um the bed lamb of uh
terrorists right and peaceful
good-hearted
uh christian american loving people
will not respond to that and the media
knows it and there's no voices
we've got voices now with the likes that
we've never had voices before
i mean go look back and all through the
80s 70s 80s 90s early 2000s
this medium didn't didn't actually take
hold until
you know the late 2000s i mean we're
talking just about 10 years ago
and so now you and i and the folks on
the scope the people in the in the crowd
and the people that are going to watch
this later on
you and i now know that we have a voice
in donald trump to say hey
y'all crazy y'all done lost your mind
and no we are conservatives we love
america
and we're as far right as you can get
meaning
we're peaceful we're loving we're caring
we help our neighbors out
we go to church we love our bibles we
love our guns the kkk the racist
individuals that they are invented by
the democrats
in order to suppress blacks black votes
and blacks that were running for office
through the republican party
but the thing is the government is
laughing
the the left is laughing the the people
in politics are laughing
saying we don't care about white
supremacy and we don't care about blm we
don't care about any race issues
we're doing this because we do not like
trump
we want trump out so we want to divide
you
we have never cared about you we have
never helped you
no and we're not about to start but
we're gonna teach you like we are
like we always say we are and we hate
trump
obama spied on a sitting president
hillary
said go for it they're trying to get him
out of there and they know the best way
they can
that's called trumple racist and then
let's get blm and the kkk and all this
white supremacy going
so that way all these podcasts will
spend 45 minutes
talking about white supremacists and blm
when the real fact of the matter is
obama and hillary set up a president
because of their dealings because of
their illegal actions that they don't
want america to find out about
including benghazi including the 780
billion dollars sent to iraq
there's so much shady stuff going on
that obama administration
the least they can do is say that
everybody's racist including trump
they want us to spend 45 minutes on this
topic they want us to talk about the 750
that trump spent with that they want us
to talk about joe's dementia
because it's not allowing you to see
what is actually behind the curtain
as comey testifies today uh
in the january fifth meeting that barack
obama had
with comey uh clapper uh uh
brandon and uh sally yates on january
5th
after trump won after obama expelled the
russian diplomats
to trigger a phone call from kislyak to
our good friend general flynn it's an
innocent call
dropped it said there was no there there
in the call left it alone
january 5th meeting happened obama said
i'm out
in 10 days right and you're literally
probably one of the top
30 people that know that right you guys
need to you're gonna still be in
you guys need to fix this
and how we're gonna fix this well we got
that general flynn call but you said
there was no there there
well let's get it let's make it there
there let's make it happen
let's change the 302s let's change
everything in the narrative
and get the russian collusion running
it's just i it almost seems so
dumbed down to argue oh trump didn't
call it white supremacy
or joe didn't call out blm i almost
feel like it's dumbed down like i can't
even believe i'm having this
conversation when there's so much more
going on
in the government that it's like wow
they actually got me
they got me hey there here i am arguing
whether or not trump should have said
this about white supremacist or joe
should have said something about blm
they got me you know look i mean look at
us all in the chat room going crazy over
it
when there's even a deeper sicker thing
going on here what what they're trying
to do and what they've done to trump
was completely illegal and now we've got
to ask the question
why do they want him out of the white
house what was he going to expose
what is going on but we're here all
talking about
white supremacy and bl actually as you
know honestly we're talking about a
whole lot more than that we're talking
about yeah
we're talking about the debate and we're
talking about things that happened
during the debate
and like i said before i i honestly i
wish you would have said it because i'm
tired of listening to the goddamn radio
over there uh
listening to the people making
commercials about it all [ __ ] morning
i'm tired of it i'm tired of it they're
using it against him
and i've said on this show many times
that president trump
is a billionaire he doesn't think like
us there are certain things that he does
um in the way that in the way that he
lives his life because he's a
billionaire he doesn't think like us
so if to him if it wasn't that important
to say it last night
that that's on him that's on him i'm
just tired of people using it against
him
i've said this before and i'll say it
again i'm tired of people attacking him
i'm talking people attacking his family
i'm tired of people attacking everything
that he's doing
trying to make this country uh um great
and
or to move it in the right direction
however there are times that he helps it
move along
but that's but but that's just who he is
that's just who he is now yes there is
white supremacy in this country
there are also a lot of white
nationalists
that uh to me the white nationalists
love this country
but if you listen to the narrative
they're trying to merge the two they're
trying to say the white nationalist
white supremacists and it's not like
that same thing
right there are black supremacists in
this country there are black
nationalists
so i mean the supremacists
does exist it does exist and
i i look i understand people want to say
well no no no
president trump there was one thing that
um um that joe biden said that was right
the fbi did come out and say that that's
one of the major problems in this
country today
is the vice president because they feel
that they have a hole
in and or they feel they can grow
what is happening in this country and
that's why you see a whole lot of stuff
happening
within these cities and they're trying
to ramp up the race they're trying to
ramp
up the race stuff because of what
happened
under the obama administration and
what's happening now
so yes there is this problem
it is not putting food on the table so
it doesn't affect
everybody it doesn't affect everybody so
i mean
you know some people are trying to go to
college some people are trying to get
jobs on
yes there are other major problems yes
but if that's what if that was the major
thing talking about last night
okay guess what we would damn sure be
talking about it right now
but that's what happened last night last
night
we had a moderator that talked his ass
off we had
um the guy on the left they couldn't
answer
basically anything and we had the guy on
the right they wouldn't let the guy
answer the other
because the other guy couldn't answer
anything so
the guy on the right was like say it go
ahead go ahead go get no no no you ain't
saying nothing
i i mean that's what happened that's the
truth that's what happened last night
now hopefully somebody is talking to
president trump for the next debate
let joe hang himself
yeah let him hang himself he'll do it he
does it all the time
he doesn't he can't hold a candle to
president trump
and i said that on the show too
joe is going to win the nomination joe
is going to be there for the debates
trump is going to win the debates that's
just that
that's that's just how i saw it because
nobody on that democratic stage
is emotional like joe and joe tried to
get a couple of those off y'all saw that
last night
um brian you saw him try to get choked
up and stuff
try to use the emotional thing nobody on
the democratic side
has the stories that joe has joe has
been here for 152 years
joe has emotional stories that will make
you
cry if he can get it in and that's what
he was trying to do
right he and and but nobody on the demo
nobody in the um
um on the democratic nom nominees and
whatnot
none of them could do that and that's
why i'm saying that's why joe
is in the position that he is right now
but when he gets on the national stage
he won't be able to be trump the only
the only person that stopped trump last
night was trump president trump
let him hang himself he gonna do it he's
going to do it
because that's his nature that's it he's
a gaff person
let him go ahead and make the gaffe and
then you know what laugh at him laugh at
him on stage you know like he latches
you
laugh at him yeah
hey did y'all get that did y'all get
that he just
he said he did it again yeah oh oh he
did it again
they said that he was role-playing with
rudy giuliani and i just think that
maybe he took rudy giuliani's advice and
i wish that he wouldn't have
because rudy can be pretty rough
yeah pretty brash pretty rough pretty
easy new yorkers
new yorker yeah new yorker to new yorker
that's exactly what happened
and that's what you got last night was
the new yorker
i mean yeah it just wasn't a good look
you didn't get the washington dc
pres president trump you got the donald
trump
of new york last night i wanted to see
the trump of hillary clinton debate
i mean trump was so on top of that
wouldn't that have been nice to see he
he he went at it at a different angle
because it was a woman
yeah i think you should treat joe biden
as a woman that's actually a really good
idea that's right
that's right it is i agree i agree
that's actually a really good i agree
with that
um and i think that we also agreed
that uh when we first started the show
and we started talking about the
possible debates and whatnot
and the possible match-up of joe biden i
think we all said
be careful how you treat him up there
because you don't want him come in the
you don't want him to have the sympathy
card the next day
you don't want job you have the sympathy
card so
don't go after his mental thing and
whatnot you know
you know don't do that uh don't make him
look small
because that's where joe
excels at playing the emotional card
and and that's and well i remember i was
talking about it
well yeah and you know hillary he didn't
handle hillary with kid gloves
i mean he's not at her but he just used
these quick real zingers like you know
well if i was president you'd be in jail
just boom quick little zingers like that
but with joe last night
like you said wayne he just kind of kept
interrupting and saying
oh what you know like it just wasn't the
trump that i'm used to seeing
right well giuliani said trump
has the right to take his head off so
that
in itself knowing that rudy was coaching
trump
rudy i think he coached me a little bit
the wrong way look at this wait a minute
you get the final word
well it's hard to get any word in with
this clown excuse me this
hey let me just tell you no no i'm mr
president
now that was a frustration thing but
guess what
president trump could have turned that
into an easy win he was like
watch this but i'm the president of the
united states
i deserve a lot more respect than what
you just gave me
boom joe you know there's kids watching
don't call me a clown that doesn't look
bad that looks bad joe i thought you
were for the kids
yeah don't do something looks bad on you
joe yeah
yeah exactly why didn't he it's just
like he was only listening to respond he
wasn't actually listening
to what joe was saying and i tell you i
tell you this
um well thirdly
we're poor the billionaires have gotten
much
much more this is the emotional side
first but
thirdly we're poor the billionaires have
gotten much
much more wealthy by a tune of over
three to four hundred billion dollars
more
just since covent you in the home you
got
less you're in more trouble than you
were before
in terms of being more violent when we
were in office there were 15 percent
less violence in america than there is
today he's president united states
it's on his watch and with regard to
more divided
the nation can't stay divided we can't
be this way
and speaking of my son the way you talk
about the military
the way you talk about them being losers
and being
and and just being suckers my son
was in iraq he spent a year there
he got he got the bronze star he got the
conspicuous service medal
he was not a loser he was a patriot
and the people left behind there were
heroes
and i resent you talking like hunter are
you talking about i'm talking about my
son beau biden you're talking i don't
know
i don't know beau i know hunter got
thrown out of the military
he was thrown out dishonorably
discharged that's not true
he he went on to talk about the cocaine
situation but as you can see
like we've been saying joe decided to go
the emotional route i'm glad trump
stopped that
right well he had to yeah he had to so
so that so did joe but then he went to
the cocaine thing
and joe went right back into the
emotional thing again
and the winning message there is hunter
and the taxes
or hunter in that situation right
president trump should have brought that
situation and kept pounding it and
pounding it
but he brought the cocaine situation in
and you know joe i mean honestly i
thought joe was going to stand up there
and cry for a second
almost well
did the smart thing by saying well my a
lot of people out there have
children that were on drugs and you know
my son is now proud because he's clean
yeah so that makes joe look good right
well yeah for that for that for that
second yeah
um kellyanne conway came out and said
that joe biden lied about her
uh she did not say that yeah right
yeah yeah um a lot about that so
she came out this morning and um respond
responded that
which is good um well here's
here's here's what the the adventist
well maybe not the administration but
here's what people on the right have
been saying
is that these riots are not hurt
they're not they're not hurting trump
they're hurting the cities
and and it's actually better people are
wanting more from trump
to to it actually helps trump it really
does help
it sounds weird and i know the way joe
threw that out there was to to bash the
administration
uh in in the way he said it but
we all know what's real we know it's
real somebody
somebody just said um president trump
should have more time to
uh respond well
if if he and wallace wouldn't have kept
on going at each other he'd probably
would have a little bit more
because in the debates in the past i've
seen it where if the candidate
says something about the other guy he
has a ministry
yeah it got like a minute to respond
like that i remember whatever happened i
remember that i thought it's funny
because
trump asked a rhetorical question to joe
and did not
request an answer and chris wallace was
like go ahead no
you asked him now let joe answer but
then when chris asked a question chris
was
and chris was like
i was being rhetorical yeah yeah wait a
minute trump was pill
yeah i mean that there's no doubt about
it you're rhetorical as a moderator
you should be you're a moderator if
you're
throwing out something rhetorical then
then you're being more than a moderator
tiger jaw has a great question why was
president trump being asked
almost every question first you know we
were talking about that coin
toss yesterday biden was supposed to be
last since trump took the first question
but in some shape or fashion
things changed and i i mean well you
know
um wallace wallace lost control of the
whole situation
it was a it was a crab show uh
and based on the rest of the moderators
wallace was probably the strongest one
so i feel sorry for the rest of the
moderators
i do i mean i really do if it if
if this happens again in their second
debate i
it's gonna be worse because the second
moderator is not gonna be able to stop
dc
it's not and like i tell my kids when
they're out there on the soccer field
playing soccer
you gotta play so well that you beat the
team
and you beat the referee's bad calls
okay
that's one thing for a referee to be bad
calls but it's another thing for the
referee to steal the ball from the kids
and kick it towards the other goal that
was
chris wallace last night
you got involved in the whole thing it
was more than a bad call
you physically implanted yourself in the
conversations
between the two candidates so that the
people saw nothing but a [ __ ]
show i'm not i'm not ashamed of my race
i can't control you digging why would
you why would you be
you could no no no no i'm talking to you
um santa claus
that scent well here's the thing you're
born the way you're born you can't
control that
yeah what you can control is you control
i'm not sure
i'm not ashamed of my race why would he
even say that when you were sticking up
for your
that doesn't matter he's racist yeah a
racist person would say something like
that
i'm not i'm not saying tomorrow just to
try to try it out yeah
okay so um with that said
it's been oh um i was supposed to be
going to um
leah i was supposed to be going to
disney tournaments
yeah are you going i actually needed to
ask you about that
that kind of looks crazy kovitt kills
more jobs disney delay off 28 000 park
employees
damn 28 thousand looks like
that's gotta wreck your comments on the
unemployment line
yeah they gotta wreck the economy wreck
it i think the cruise ship industry is
done
yeah it's just so tough to get people on
a cruise ship all combined
and together like that what are you
going to do yeah yeah out on the water
you know miles away from
the states and then what happens if
covet comes then you're stuck back out
there
and then you got to wear your mask while
you're on the deck and you know they
have all those buffets you have to shut
them down you can only bring yourself
your tables you know there's no windows
i just think that
i think the cruise ship is it's gone
and i don't know if it'll ever return
until you know there's an actual
covet's gone i don't know i feel bad for
the cruise ship industry i do
speaking about ridiculous new york state
file lawsuit against cuomo for forced
mask wearing and co-ed restrictions he
said he's gonna find
him brian there you go they just filed a
lawsuit
against uh mike dewine here in ohio
it's pretty big deal people are pissed
it's too much
it's too much it's too much it's got to
stop this whole cobot thing's got to
stop
i woke up in a bad mood this morning and
i blame it on the debate last night
but man i had an eye appointment i got
triggered
i'm the only one in the entire i'm the
only you got call
from the parking lot to be allowed in
i'm the only one in the entire waiting
area
and they have glass windows closed for
behind the counter
i sat all the way across the room on a
very far side
and i dropped the mask down off my face
she come out the window
i said i'm six feet and then we got into
it gone
arguing match and she's like that's
posse you talked to the doctor
i said all right i will i'll get with
him here in a minute went back in the
back i said are you the doctor she said
no
you need to pull that up over your nose
i'm like oh
so i finally saw the doctor i said
w-h-o-c-d-c dr fauci
i'm telling you right now this thing has
to stop it's because people like you
that are continuing this well you're in
my office
you want to check your eyes that's true
yeah pull it up
gotta follow the rolls if you wanted to
of course he did he look at his glasses
i want to get i want to get my fade my
lady
penny shout out to penny who loves the
show uh
i went to go see her and she's like
brian you know if the state comes in
they'll shut me down i said i know i
know you got to but
but when when the overreach of the
government
to shut these businesses down and take
them out of business
because of a freaking mask well get used
to it if joe gets in because he's going
to make it mandatory
so just get used to it if he gets it and
what about the new york uh
city election board saying that nearly a
hundred thousand brooklyn voters
received wrong ballot return envelopes
dude that's bad oops oops
then thousands thousands here thousands
there a couple thousand here the final
let me let me say this um because
you know i treasure my i treasure my
co-host
but you ain't leave y'all oh yeah uh i
trust you i trust my co-host i think
i think my co-hosts are the most we we
agree on a lot
we disagree on little uh
but for me i don't have any problem with
the mass i really don't
i don't either i wear it i've been like
that i mean i don't have any problem
with it because
i if if aids was out there
i wouldn't want anybody saying yeah the
mass will lose our liberty and
i mean or you know get it from a toilet
seat some other
type of uh uh the blue bonic plague
it's called spreading you know yeah it
is
actually i would want everybody
if i was to treat people with respect i
would want people to treat me with
respect and
uh as long as you are an adult
and you have to fight and to fight the
will ain't nobody going to take your
liberty
nobody's going to take your liberty just
like i don't know whether it's like when
um joe biden was like they gonna put
y'all back and change
how many of y'all after that they're
gonna put you all back in chains
if they thought it was ridiculous okay i
was actually sad
the same thing is with taking liberty
they they're not taking the second
amendment away from us
they're not um they're not gonna take uh
uh
our liberty away they're not gonna put
anybody back in chains
these are well i hate to say it's dog
whistles but
uh these are statements to
put fear in people so so that people
give that type of action but you know
leah lee and me you know we
if we i mean and you have to wear
because of the policy
that's the policy right if you don't
like the policy find someone
and and i'm inviting right i'm not with
you
i'm mad at the policy for this different
mike dewine that's who i'm mad about
i'm mad that these businesses are in
lockstep
well i mean i mean but the businesses
are looking out for in um
right don't go in there if you've got
coving
if you don't know right right they're
saying that you can't transfer it if
you're not showing signs
said it too he said that it was killing
a lot of people he said it on tape
president trump said that w.h.o said if
you're not showing signs
yeah it's very very hard if you're not
showing signs to give it all
some people should be caught some people
should be quarantined
i'm telling you you're not i'm telling
you what the president said okay
i'm telling you what the president get
the president i'm talking what's real
if you're quarantining people that
aren't sick
yeah that's called tyrion yeah
i can fix this real easy the problem
with it is if asymptomatic people do not
spread it that's fine
and then brian would be right but here's
the problem
most people don't know when they have a
low-grade fever
that's considered a symptom so when
you're walking into a business
but most people don't most children do
not most adults
not tell women no brain is 99.1 that's
considered a low grade
fever and you would be shocked at how
many people
are walking around with a 99.1 fever
that's low grade and that's considered a
symptom and it can be spread
and 93 survival rate right but i'm just
i'm just trying to defend wayne here
when when i tell you that
people don't even realize they have
symptoms until after they've spread it
again 93 or higher survival rate
and how many times has leah said but we
don't know the long
tight condition we don't know i don't
know if god's gonna show up tomorrow and
say hey guys we're going home
i had kovacs the lawsuits that are gonna
come out ten years from now from
forced mask wearing or or class action
lawsuits or
for having a disease and their parents
dying
and those lawsuits come out that they
weren't notified
immediately we didn't know
get rid of it don't use it no more when
they found out though they sued didn't
he
right okay we don't but we can't
base today on what tomorrow might or
might not be
but you have to when it comes to people
dying
right no they're surviving
and they're dying too they're dying they
call it they may not be dying
hold on they're gonna die from the flu
they might not be dying on a large scale
and let me tell you something i didn't
even tell you that my husband got tested
for the antibodies
he didn't have coven i didn't give it to
him
isn't that interesting type o he's type
o they're saying typos
yeah they're saying typos cannot get
coven and now we're finding out that he
didn't have it and he has type of blood
type
he does not have the oven i did have the
cobin
sanitizer well see look you're
uneducated because i have the covered
antibodies which mean i am not
i'm playing i'm not contagious
no one knows the answers to anything
because none of us know
none of us know i'm suing you though
yeah i'm sure nobody knows the answers
nobody knows what's right what's wrong
what's up what's up all we know is that
some people get covered and die and some
don't i wear a mask because
like what wayne says i want to respect
other people who are very afraid
i'm not afraid anymore all people will
always say to me why are you wearing a
mask
if you already had covet because i just
want to calm down anybody who is a
smash freak i'm just doing it for their
sake i'm playing in to their city
okay i'll tell you
there was a guy that said he he had uh
leukemia
or he's battling leukemia or something
or other
and i was like enough said
enough said i don't want to be in your
shoes i don't want your life and i
understand
that that what you got going on right
now are you talking about your doctor
no some other guy some guy i was doing
work for
yeah no i'll never see that doctor again
we have this person last but leah hold
on someone's saying something
but leah if you had it you're not
contagious nor susceptible right
but if i'm in walmart nobody knows that
i had it judy
so i just wear the mask to keep
everybody else calm
just a respect thing i don't think
that's the only reason
i just i just wear it because i see
mothers angels
i see mothers with children who i once
did not wear it into walmart and i saw a
mother with a child who was scared i
could tell that she was worried
i saw an elderly woman who rushed away
from me and i thought you know what
i don't want to put them in that subject
they might be having a worse day they
might not be able to pay their bills
they might have a family member who's
dying of cancer and now they are going
to think in the back of their mind that
blonde lady who didn't have a damn mask
on
did she get me covered now i'm going
home to my cancer husband
i don't want anybody to feel that way so
i just keep my mask on
for others i can't be an appeaser like
that i can't
i can't lose that that's not anything
that's what would jesus do that's what
jesus now
i'm not here to make someone feel
uncomfortable right
jesus is not making people feel
comfortable jesus is being
in just the being with god well i'm not
i'm saying
i'm brian what i'm trying to say is he
wants you to have peace with everybody
and love thy neighbor
and if you're not wearing your mask and
your neighbor's worried that you might
give them covet
then you're not loving anybody that's
the only reason why i wear it no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no that's not right
in walmart boys you might believe into
all of it my foil-lined hat it's not
appeasing someone it's just
trying to and and look and i'm with her
i'm not aware what are y'all i'm gonna
wear it because
i want people to to know that i care for
them just like i would
want people to care for me i don't feel
my liberties are being taken
i need people to know that this is a man
oaks this is that mask
these are jokes think about that for a
mask my liberties are being taken
no i don't i don't feel that way a lot
of people do
well okay that's why people do my
liberties are being taken because i
gotta stick to policy
and we're a mess just let everybody know
i don't like wearing the mask
it's ridiculous and i can't stand my
governor for making me wear it
but i'm doing it because i don't want
the elderly lady who does believe
who is a democrat who is a crazy liberal
who believes that she's gonna die of
this coven
to be afraid when she goes home i just
don't want to be like that
where's the faith okay right right i
just don't
i tell you that i tell you it is um
i wouldn't well whatever i'm just trying
to be
no no i'm not going to feel believe me
i'm not saying the mass protection i
haven't come out and slammed the ones
that are wearing the man i mean
that excuse me that won't mirror that
won't that won't wear it
but i support those that
do and i'm going to support those that
do because
i have some children and we have been
fine
as long as we have been following the
rule you're talking about a house
that has a certain amount of people in
it and if you look at
the numbers that have been going up in
them
in the kind of stuff that not one person
in my house has got it
now why nobody here no we we've got
dozens of people coming in and out the
whole time
i i i did get it um no the blonde lady's
not going to spend her whole life making
sure everyone is comfortable with
everything she does
that's not me at all in fact i probably
make everybody feel uncomfortable
because i speak my mind and tell it how
it is i just don't care about the mess
because i'm stronger mentally than that
i don't care anyways it doesn't matter
to me
if i want to if i want to wear my mask
i'll wear it it does not bother me
it might be because my medical
background a math to me was just second
nature anytime that i had to do anything
so it doesn't matter to me but i'm not
yeah i don't feel bad for wearing one
and i don't feel bad for not wearing one
trunk
now when i go down south a little bit
where it's more republican
i don't wear a mask oh well i i don't
wear one because
someone else is wearing one but if
everybody else is wearing one then i'm
like okay
did leah just call brian simple-minded
no no
brian's a healer i'm the one i'm the guy
at ikea when they when a young kid the
youth
asked me where's your mask at i said oh
i i can't wear one
he said oh oh okay well go down to the
front door and ask the guy for a
wristband
i said oh okay thanks man so i went down
there i got the wristband
he gave me i'm walking around employees
coming up people coming out hey oh
yeah oh no no i'm protected i got the
wristband
and i tell you this and i'll tell you
this my mom is 93 or 94 years old
i can't take that chance
my mom's in her 70s mid 70s i
i can't and i'm not i'm i mean uh
i was what i was worrying about her i
mean i even got her mask and stuff like
that but
i worry about her all the time you know
because i still believe
covet is that switch it's a switch
that finds that trigger and flips off
and that flips on something and
and takes out the people that are weak
or or
those those ones are underlying
conditions i've always felt like that
because when you start hearing well uh
this person down the cover but they had
underlying condition well this
person died and they had underlying okay
so before kobe came they had unlimited
conditions but they were still alive
and then they got covered and then and
because and
and then the underlying conditions that
they had they're gone
i was like that thing must cert must go
through your body and find whatever it
is
and flip that switch man well because is
dangerous
my cousin was 47 he died a covet in may
i had coveted messed up my blood sugars
pretty bad but i will say one thing i
will agree with people
i had to wear my mask for the longest
amount of time that i ever had
uh last saturday night ex no the
saturday before
for like six straight hours it was
miserable and i will tell you
the next day i had a sore throat that
lasted three days you know what
i don't like i went to atlanta um a few
weeks ago
and i wore my mask for the longest
getting on the plane being on the plane
getting off the plane
um in the car driving to the hotel
lobby the hotel wherever i had to walk
around the hotel
i i had to wear the day the day after i
came back
you remember i told you yeah it felt
like an empty chest feeling yeah and
well you know we we found out that it
might have been something else but
yeah um it was like it
it felt like i had a hollow hollowness
right here
and i was like damn i'm breathing kind
of i was like man i hope i didn't you
know something
you know because we also had a a a
military guy
who was walking around the airport
without a mass and that guy just
happened to be in the seat
in front of me now did that worry you
now did that
come across your mind yeah you know did
that guy give me covet
that's honestly the only reason i wear
masks so that way i'm not worrying other
people
i thought but my one of my best friends
is a laboratory scientist who i just got
to see
over the weekend this is alarming you
guys and
i can't mention her name or where she
works but she does work hand in hand
with what's going on with cobot
and they just received an email out that
said
that the flu shot is going to make you
more sick this year it's going to cause
a stronger headache because the flu shot
itself
they have made stronger because they
fear coveting the flu mixed
so i don't get the flu shot i don't know
if you guys do
but that really is scary about the flu
shot no
never ain't getting that i ain't getting
i got too many shots in the air force
they gave us too many yeah i got enough
i got enough for two lifetimes yeah i
graduated from that
yeah i won't i won't do it i got i got
my diploma i'm i'm out i'm out so for
those of you that's on the fence about
the flu shot
i don't know because she said she got it
and it gave her a severe headache and
they said yeah
we're making it stronger a stronger
batch this year just to really amp it up
and they're really not coming out and
telling people that i probably should
you did call that brian you said that a
few weeks ago
yeah i'm done i mean give me a shot i'm
gonna give you a shot
that's just how it is okay ladies and
gentlemen we we have we have one more
day this week
i'm going to sleep i'm tired yeah you
need to you've been up for 26 hours
you don't tell me what i need i told you
i ain't afraid of you
well you need help no fear no fear no
fear
no get it brian
oh we're done we're exhausted no more
debates no more arguing
a long day the pence and harris one will
be a spiritual one so
that's it that'd be the devil in jesus
believe me i bet you they talk more
about religion than anything i bet you i
i promise
it's it's gonna be like amoxicillin and
herpes
pence is the amoxicillin how do you she
is the herpes
what do you mean willie brown you know
all about her give amoxicillin
moxie stealing cure herpes i don't know
[ __ ] does it brian i don't know that's
why i'm asking you
no there is no cure for herpes
see the commercial on tv they're having
all kinds of fun they're going hiking
and
fishing and camping i want to get what
they got
yeah and they're not wearing masks no
no all kinds of stuff
i have herpes too oh man it looks like
he's there
look at that no mask he's fishing
i think he's been up for 24 hours wow
that looks fun abravia i think it's
called brevia you can get there
on the lips and put your stuff on
oh look he must have herpes he's happy
that was just gay i don't answer unknown
names
okay so um all right we'll be back
tomorrow
and get some tiredness um
they went 90 minutes without going to
the bath and i've gone 12 and a half
hours
going to the bathroom that's a and
that's a race that from our memory last
night
yeah that debate let's just erase it i
can't
i know it's 90 minutes we can never get
back yeah
it was [ __ ] show